and carlos hernandez against alec mills
well we know that he's been better as a
starter than he was as a reliever we
know that he's been really good he's
four and one with an era right around
three
and a swing and a miss and mills
strikes him out that's a pretty good
change lopez retired and now it is
salvador perez one hit his catcher was
this guy hit softly to third bare
handing wisdom to first nice play
seven pitches they go one two three
patrick wisdom tested right there
a plus gets the catcher one two three go
the royals here come the cubs carlos
hernandez who's been on a an impressive
role over his last four starts schwendel
a former royal like alec mills he was
their opening day first baseman in 2019
and that one laced into left center
field that's a base hit patrick wisdom
the 3-2 pitch
jammed him inside with the fastball and
swung on that missed andrew benetendi is
hit in seven straight the cubs who had a
need
past schwendell duffy is there and ben
and tendy beats the throw to mills and
now carlos santana the batter
carlos lines it right side and it's
going to be off of duffy's glove
so he kept it from going into the
outfield but he's upset that the cubs
didn't get it out and the royals have
two on with nobody out so here's hunter
dozier who is making his first start of
the series
and raising some big money out over the
plate and that's down
here comes benintendi
and the throw goes all the way to the
cut-off man and dozier takes another 90
feet
so he gets an rbi to put the royals in
front
and with heads up base running
the royals have runners at second and
third and nobody out clean
rbi single
but that hustle man that makes up a lot
east royalty never stop
and a swing and a miss pretty good job
of damage control
with all the traffic
royals score one or midway in the second
sergio
alcantara
that helps he gets a chase at 98 that's
his second strikeout and the cubs go
down in order in the second most recent
member of
500 home runs and 3 000 hits there's a
base hit left field for witt
he is one for two nikki lopez struck out
on a change up his first time up
base hit into center field for nicki and
that'll get whit first to third
and runners at the corners with nobody
out an attendee single to the second
baseman duffy
and attendee goes to center field and
he's going to get him both home
i'm not sure that was a strike and now
in at second base he was able to get
around the tag so he gets two rbis and
that's the second time in two innings
but the royals have been heads up on a
throw in from ortega and took another 90
feet royals on the attack that's the
changeup it was a good change up too
down low ben and tindy went to one knee
even all the way down to just to lift
and stay inside that ball that was
pretty
and look at this he says i can get two
nifty slide there
looked like duffy was able to get the
glove in front of the base but ben
attendee said uh-uh
the pitcher alec mills
and he got him with 95 and that is
carlos's third strikeout ortega popped
out to lopez it's short in the first
inning the right with this left-handed
hitter up there fastball hit well deep
center taylor back taylor makes the
catch right in front of the ivy in
center field he had him played right and
on the perfect side of the field he was
a little bit to shade opposite field
there and good concentration and by the
way oh man he did a nice job of getting
that ball keeping that ball in his glove
and he'll lead off the fourth inning
fastball again
on the ground base hit left field
tough pitch down and in and he's on to
begin the fourth inning and here's
emmanuel rivera
just crazy memory look at that swaying
inside out by rivera
and the royals
are putting on a first to third clinic
today so here's whit with a chance of
driving a run he is one for two
and his stroke to left field and caught
taylor tags and comes down from third so
whit gets the job done with a sac fly
mickey singled stole second base and
scored there to even run yeah
and now it's stroked into right center
field
beautiful job so that stolen base ends
up being huge for the royals nikki lopez
has two more hits five in his last two
games at wrigley field and the royals
lead is five nothing in the fourth half
wisdom and duffy was then and before
in the air out towards right center
field that's pretty well struck taylor
out there and oh
and it falls and bounces over the wall
it's an automatic double dozier and
taylor
and it looked like dozier made the call
and then decided
to let taylor have it and michael had
peeled off
one down there's matt duffy now
ground ball base hit right field
charging as dozier harris gonna send him
throw to the plate and it's cut off tag
safe
duffy back in rbi single the cubs are on
the board
andrew benintendi leads off for a second
time he's two for two with a run scored
and two rbis he went all the way down
his knee and doing it again there is
that part of the highlight reel we just
ran
it is now
come on he is three for three that was
clean carlos reached on an air in the
second inning and he's fly it out to
center field running and santana strokes
it to right and that's going to be
inside the line and off the netting
ben attendee goes to third and holds
and the royals have runners at second
and third and nobody out dozier drove in
a run in the second inning and then he
flied to the warning track in left in
the third
and dozier hits it to right field that
is to the gap and it's a slide a bobble
and was it a catch
oh man
uh everybody's gonna have to lock the
brakes up now he he came out of his
glove but
but it might have rolled on in his body
i don't think he'd hit the ground he was
able to cradle it against his body
gather it in and then turn and make the
throw home
second and third nobody out
to left field
hap gets behind it santana tags
and the throw comes to the infield so
carlos now joins the group
now seven
of the nine have either driven in a run
or scored a run wood needs a multi-hit
over the mound over the bag and into
center field and there's your
multi-hit game hud there you go what a
nickname huh
and that's up and away
for a walk so nikki's on for a third
time andrew benintendi's had a great day
one out in that inning but it looked
like
mills might get out of that one ben
attendee is going to get
a sacrifice fly as the throw goes toward
third so he has driven in three
witt has scored twice he is one for
three with a double and a run scored
slice to left and that's over a leaping
ian happ
nikki lopez will score
carlos santana drives in his first run
so nikki has scored twice and now the
royals lead is 9-1 in the sixth inning
yeah good pitch down but out over the
plate but even better swing
season sided second double on the day
austin romine has flied to left field
and grounded out to short
romine is down on strikes and that is
seven for hernandez
hernandez ties his career high with six
and two-thirds innings he has struck out
eight
here's wade davis
that's well hit to center field taylor
is there and the royals
sweep the series they have won four in a
row on the road
and they finished the year
12 and eight against the national league
you